this is what Nintendo originally was yes
it was a playing card company and this
is Nintendo today
consoles theme parks even movies
so what has driven the 44 Billion Dollar
Empire this is the economics of
Nintendo
Nintendo is different from its
competitors Sony and Microsoft thanks in
part to its low-cost Hardware
Microsoft's Xbox makes no profit on its
Hardware
consoles are actually sold at a loss in
the market so when somebody goes and
they buy an Xbox at their local retailer
we're subsidizing that purchase
somewhere between 100 and 200 with the
expectation that we will recoup that
investment over time through accessory
sales and storefront and Sony only
recently began to make a profit on the
PlayStation 5. then there's Nintendo
technology is usually five or six years
behind in terms of state of the art but
that means that they're cheaper to
produce and that means that Nintendo is
much much more profitable on their
Hardware business about half of
Nintendo's profit in 2022 came from
Hardware Sales they've dominated the
market when it comes to handheld
consoles one of its big successes the
Game Boy launched in 1989
Nintendo was really early to the party
uh with handheld they're kind of
credited with inventing the console
although they were probably third or
fourth the game boy had a longer battery
life compared to some of its competitors
four Shades of Gray nuanced gameplay and
had Tetris one of the top selling video
games of all time eventually Nintendo's
Game Boy became the third most sold
console in the company's history selling
119 million units to date the company
continued to innovate releasing new
hardware for its games from the GameCube
Nintendo DS the Wii and to its most
recent success the switch with more than
122 million units sold you can play it
at home like a console on your big
screen TV but you could pick it up and
take it on the go and it becomes a
handheld device and that's pretty novel
we haven't really seen anything that's a
hybrid like that before sales of the
switch device and its games accounted
for about 94 of Nintendo's sales revenue
in its 2021 fiscal year and today it's
the SEC second best-selling game console
in Nintendo's history and continues to
be a driving factor of its Revenue the
success of Nintendo's consoles is also
due to its software in other words it's
games in 2022 Nintendo had 19 first
party titles that sold over a million
units each exclusive to its consoles the
difference between the others and
Nintendo is that Nintendo historically
has produced about 50 percent of all the
games sold on its Hardware system and
the other guys are typically under 10
percent of the game sold on their
systems so they make a small fraction of
the software that's played on
Playstation Xbox Nintendo makes more
than half case in point Animal Crossing
New Horizons release in April 2020
created higher demand for the only
console carrying it the switch Nintendo
makes games exclusively for the most
part for its own devices if you want to
play a Nintendo game like Legend of
Zelda you need Nintendo Hardware in fact
Nintendo's first party games generate
over 70 percent of its sales its best
sellers in 2022 were all Nintendo first
party games and the type of content
Nintendo makes is also different than
its competitors let's keep in mind
Nintendo characters are very cute
Mario
Nintendo is known for making family
friendly games for the most part so it
appeals to a different crowd than some
of the other Publishers you won't see
blood or Gore or foul language but even
Nintendo a couple years ago dowled into
the shooter genre when we think of
Shooters right we think of Call of Duty
fortnite uh they take a very
family-friendly approach with Splatoon
it's a shooter but you're shooting
paintballs the company's next iteration
bringing these family-friendly
characters to a larger Arena and
building another generation of fans in
February 2023 Nintendo opened its first
theme park outside of Japan and in April
it's releasing a Super Mario Brothers
movie starring Chris Pratt it's a me a
Mario that's smart because that's gonna
expose the Nintendo brand to hundreds of
millions of people who haven't ever
owned a switch I don't think that
Nintendo is necessarily worried about
whether somebody who goes to the theme
park will buy a Nintendo console or buy
a game
but they want those people to be aware
of the Nintendo Brands and they want
them to know who Mario is and who Zelda
is and who Yoshi is and who Pikmin is it
is risky to start a new franchise and
sometimes new properties just don't
resonate but they have plenty a very
deep library and they've stuck with that
for the most part and iterated on it and
modernized it we'll probably be playing
Legends of Zelda for another 20 30 years
Mario is probably not going anywhere you
know he's just gonna live forever and
keep that mustache and keep everyone
happy for many years to come
[Music]
thank you